You'll be challenged, inspired, motivated and humbled.
Your life will have new meaning.
Peace, health, serenity, happiness, nirvana.
The price?
$55,000, and that's an incredible deal.
By now I know you're dying to know what it is and where you can get one.
Does Amazon carry it?
Does it have the Apple logo on it?
Is there a waiting list?
Not likely.
This gift came to me about five months ago.
It looked more like this when it was all wrapped up - not quite so pretty.
And this, and then this.
It was a rare gem - a brain tumor, hemangioblastoma - the gift that keeps on giving.
And while I'm okay now, I wouldn't wish this gift for you.
I'm not sure you'd want it.
But I wouldn't change my experience.
It profoundly altered my life in ways I didn't expect in all the ways I just shared with you.
So the next time you're faced with something that's unexpected, unwanted and uncertain,...
...consider that it just may be a gift.